yo here we go again welcome to this
video it is a black game against bulge
thrower okie dokie he's playing the f3
and tie Kings in Europe trying something
funky here let's see can can we do
something interesting here if he goes d
far they have 94 seems interesting nope
he's just covering things um is there
some tactic no I don't think so so I'm
going to take why not it looks ok then
rupee 8 what is there to think about
cannot take with the bishop in this
position giving up the dark squared dark
squared bishop ok so this is very
similar to the classical Kings Indian in
fact if he goes Bishop e2 we will
transpose and Bishop b2 looks like the
most normal move either probably i don't
even have something else like Bishop e2
g6 that's their know is keeping keeping
the night on interesting so how do i
play that probability 66 first and see
from there hmm interesting I wonder if
night h5 something like that is is a
possibility here or is this just just
bad
not sure not very well versed in this
kind of position if he cancels i cannot
go f5 and maybe i can maybe i can
actually takes bishop cheeks i'm
checking see tune now it's possible if
he goes f4 i can prolly take c3 and play
Knight f6 to win the epon still
expecting them to Castle maybe Queen d2
Queen d2 as an alternative for sure but
then Queen h4 as an additional idea that
I have yeah I'm kind of kind of
reinventing the wheel here because it's
not my usual type of position but wanted
to try out something else okay so what
about f5 is this on f5 he takes it
Bishop takes g4 Bishop see to that
should be quite good for black I guess
okay it's difficult not to play a five
in the long run and need some kind of
play against this pawn bind cannot just
sit around now if he takes I will play
Bishop checks why is there some
alternative let's just for a moment now
probably not if he takes I can pre move
Bishop f5 and there is some likelihood
that team that you might take but ok can
castle of course
let's enter the pre move again is taking
taking really long here okay um that's
an interesting situation now how to play
if I take you for you probably chick
with the night now not probably he will
check with the night Bishop g5 could be
could be really tricky that may be to
Hanks but I don't really think I can
take it ok let's take the pawn some
night takes I mean Bishop b2 looks looks
very very cheeky one move that always
irritates me as a possible Bishop g5 as
90 of six is kind of pinning myself or
he takes with the pawn I didn't expect
that at all hmm so what is the thing
Bishop g5 is the problem probably I
wonder if I have the option to play
Queen to g5 a queen to h4 I'm sorry
Bishop g5 I cannot play Bishop age six
ok so probably no it's maybe taking my
man I'd damn sorry but if i go back to
f6 he's playing Bishop g5 I guess hmm
quite problematic
Queen edge for Bishop g5 is this is
really dropping the Queen I don't think
I can afford can afford that line hmm
maybe this one okay if it takes h5 off
then you will take it not much that I
can do yeah if chick so I really didn't
take into account but it's not that bad
the open air file was giving up some
play I think you should just take h5 now
this is really a really an uncomfortable
situation for me always taking ages
being slower than then I am is quite
quite something yeah now is Bishop g5 an
Assessor it's the real problem yeah but
do I do here I take it I'm giving away
upon but my queen takes and the Queen I
tried but maybe I still should do it the
night is really is really strong them so
I'm rather give up this upon them okay I
can take e for anyway so this is maybe
not such a big problem yeah okay this
might be might be not that bad okay do a
top kid sorry do I take you for not hmm
i have rookie five as an alternative but
ok let's take it
and ask questions later maybe look up 70
when I have rook h4 that's an
interesting resource tempo on the Queen
okay he threatens to take and then and
check me boo through 57 hmm my rook is a
very loose piece rookie seven maybe time
morning let's do that Bishop g5 I have
rupee five so Knight e5 is a possible
way to improve my position okay that set
could be okay there's nothing not
thrilled here but it seems solid yeah
he's taking a long time again I take you
one okay that's not a huge deal i think
he cannot check check me on f7 as a pin
look f7 is not legal
and I have 95 now 95 keeping things
protected okay so what about this
Queenie 825 yep probably check have to
be really careful them so night h5 is
this idea huh dangerous it's really
dangerous
Jeff he only has two seconds they're
white forfeits on time yeah I wasn't
quick 27 moves i have seven seconds left
but he spent even more time yeah i had
to defend very yeah good game was an
interesting game definitely so let's
let's have a look that was interesting
yeah maybe with hindsight I really don't
like my decision to take their F cakes
is really a problem I I didn't really
take that too seriously but it is good I
should probably play differently maybe
just put the night back or something I
don't know I don't know many many ideas
but this is surprisingly tricky now Jim
I can go back to have 67 this is he put
this out and now he s yeah I asked those
things yeah but you can go King go here
and then double I'm really under
pressure really under pressure in this
production Jim and this is this is now
just better for him I think this was
right chatting rid of them getting rid
of this here I suspect I'm okay but I am
queen yay that's was that that is an
alternative I wasn't sure checks takes
Queen somewhere I don't know now
probably i'm okay i have from have a
decent decent control is probably about
equal and it's probably better than than
rookie seven but check computer is
always on about equal so maybe i am not
in such bad shape queen here and now he
gives widen advantage
not a win but an advantage check and now
he can take and play this which is very
strong yeah okay well i only hear i also
was playing with some second snap that's
quite strong I cannot go ruki eight
there because of Knight f6 and it's
really made next smooth just made and no
I have no moves yeah I can move the
night enter well I'm just losing the
house there I don't know I'm
american-made now the city was that was
a really kind of a lucky win what is he
writing yeah he said he ran out of time
but he played a very very decent game
always keeping keeping something maybe I
had equal play it at one or two spots
but white was was calling the shots all
of the time so on was a good game name
is just far too slow yep now I really
played well but it's just um it doesn't
matter at the end if you are too slow i
mean i have lost so many games with bad
time management it's beyond belief okay
well glad to have a winnin even though
it was a bit lucky thanks for watching